Despite being an O-mazing and near universal phenomenon
There's still a lot of speculation around the orgasms function and value
But what are the differences between male and female orgasm that we know of and who has it better
To start the length of a woman's orgasm is longer than men lasting around 20 seconds or more
While most men tend to last around 3 to 10 seconds
but men have more orgasms
In a national australian survey of heterosexual sex, researchers found that men had an orgasm 95% of encounters
Wile women did only 69% of the time
However orgasm might have less to do with gender and more to do with the types of sex you're having
For example, a study of single americans aged 21 to 26 found that while straight and gay men's  rate of orgams is simiar
The rate of orgasms rate for women vary very significantly by sexual orientation
Lebians have around 12% more orgasm than straigh women during sex
With 25& of gay women saying they climax with every sexual expirience and almost half saying they climax over 75% of the time
This may be related to the duration of sexual encounters
As lesbian couples reported an average length of 30 to 45 minutes
In comparison to the average of 15 to 30 minutes by straight women
Other explanation point to genetics
Studies of 4.000 females twins found that genetics predict the thrids of the probabilities that a woman orgasm during sex
But what about the way an orgasm feels?
Studies of college students asked men and women to describe their expiriences of an orgasm
and then later took out the words related to specific genitals
And it turns out that there was very little distinguishable difference between sexes
Regardless of your gender the brain stimulates blood flow to the genitals and your hearthbeat and breathing increase
While ... scans show significant differences in activation patterns during sexual arousal
Brain activity during and orgasm itself , it's the same between men and women
The lateral orbital frontal cortex which controls self-evaluation, reason and  control shuts down in all genders
Which makes sense as you often lose control during an orgasm
And the similarities don't stop there
Both genders get drowsy after orgasm due to the surge in the sleeping hormone prolactine
Interestingly 4 times as much prolactin is realeased after intercourse compared to orgasm achieve via masturbation
Meaning you don't get sleepy after a solo session
And what we once thought was spontaneous orgams  during sleep otherwise known as wet dreams were only for men
One study reports that 37% of women have had nocturnal orgasms
30% had had one in the past year
Even muliple orgasm. A phenomeon thought to be exclusively for  women
as they lack of refractory period
has been seen in men as well
Though men orgasms generally happens simultaneously with ejaculation
Research has documented that men are capable of non ejaculatory orgasm
That can occur prior to as well as afer ejaculation
This shared experience of the orgasm makes sense from a evulationary perspective
Just like when you see someone cry and feel sad for them because you understand it
Observing or being part of a partner's orgams can enhanse the desire and experience of your own
If we had completely different orgasms the same connection wouldn't be there
At the end of the day, while sexual arousal may be different for men and women
Major difference in orgasm experiences likely come down to the individual level
Differences in physiology, anatomy and our psychology play huge role
So get to know your own body to optimize your sexual experiences
You can always learn even more about  sexual pleasure during your solo session in our video
Is masturbation good for you?
LInk in the description below
And a special thanks to audible for supporting this episode
To give you a free 30% audible trial at audible.com/asap
This week we wanted to recommend the book
What if we we're wrong
Which question everything we think we know in today's world and how it may appear to those in the far future
Pretty neat
You can get a free 30-day trial at audible.com/asap and choose from our massive selection
We love them, they are great when you're on the go
And subscribe for more weeky science videos